ground news is combating divisiveness
in media ground is a news comparison
platform
that helps you see multiple perspectives
for any news story
so you can be more of a well-rounded
news reader
download the free app at ground dot news
pacman there is a huge scientific and
societal pressure that's growing
on the covet anti-vaxxers that are still
refusing to get the coronavirus vaccine
as we are now starting to see more than
half of the united states see
an increase in cases thanks mostly
to the very contagious delta variant
spreading
in particular among unvaccinated people
and of course because no vaccine is 100
effective of the coveted vaccines that
we currently have
uh by sheer math also picking off
some people who did do the right thing
and did go and get themselves vaccinated
and so
it's overwhelmingly happening in the
least vaccinated counties
this is translating to happening more in
red states
than in blue states and yesterday i
already told you about the stunning
numbers which show
that in may i mean look at this in may
99.2 of those who died of coronavirus
were not vaccinated while 0.8
of those who died had been vaccinated
maryland says that 100
of covet 19 deaths last month
were among the unvaccinated so this is
this is no joke the numbers are
to call them overwhelming is really an
understatement and it's getting
so bad in other words the impact
of not being vaccinated is so huge
on a country or a state or even
on a county's health system that people
are going crazy trying to figure out
what is it going to take to get
people vaccinated so that we can stop
the development of new variants
and the the evolution of new variants
and stop the spread
among mostly unvaccinated people but
still affecting the vaccinated as well
because no vaccine is 100 effective now
in the united states
we're not going to see government
mandatory vaccinations
employers can certainly legally require
employees to be vaccinated
in most cases to go back to an in-person
working situation some countries are
taking a much more authoritarian
approach we're not going to see this in
the united states
but tajikistan and the vatican are
imposing mandatory vaccination on adults
straight up
period in italy there are
several counties or territories that
have imposed
mandatory vaccination on certain
sections of the population
italian doctors and health workers in
both the public and private sector must
be vaccinated or they will face
not being allowed to work directly with
patients which will make it really
difficult for them to do their jobs
the british government in mid-june said
all home care staff
must be fully vaccinated to continue
working
kazakhstan on july 1st ordered
mandatory coronavirus vaccinations for a
wide range of workers who come into
contact with others now in the united
states we're not going to see that
i'm not an advocate of that i am an
advocate of people getting vaccinated
and we have to figure out how to get
them to do it
we have some examples in the u.s like
the city of san francisco they've said
it's going to require
municipal employees to be vaccinated
or they could face penalties up to and
including dismissal
but that's only when there's full fda
approval
of the vaccine houston methodist
hospital in texas more than 150
employees have been fired or resigned
because
they didn't comply with their employer
directive to get themselves vaccinated
the delta variant is less well handled
by the current vaccines and we're
already seeing
a more contagious lambda variant appear
in australia
we still don't know that much about it
so like this is the key time
do we want a resurgence of this in the
fall do we want to have to go back
this fall to the direction of hopefully
not as bad but the direction of the way
things were last fall
and yes almost half of u.s reports
of u.s states are reporting rising cases
largely because of this delta variant
about 157 million americans right now
uh 58 of us adults
are fully vaccinated 67 percent of u.s
adults have had at least
one shot we are getting there we we did
not meet joe biden's goal of 70
by july 4th hopefully by next week this
weekend or early next week
we will get to that point but what is it
going to take
to get these people vaccinated because
otherwise
it will be more variants and more spread
and eventually it will be more deaths as
well
if we get a variant that really evades
the vaccines
and has a higher death rate understand
that to say that we've been lucky about
anything in this pandemic it feels
crass it feels outrageous to say
uh but i encourage you
read lauren's wright's latest book the
end of october it's it's a novel it's
fiction
but it's clearly based around a
coronavirus-like global pandemic
we're lucky that the real world
coronavirus for now doesn't have
nearly the death rate that the imaginary
uh
virus in lawrence wright's book the end
of october has because if we had
and we could have a much more deadly
variant
uh the numbers will be even more
horrifying than what the us and the
world has already endured so what will
it take to get these folks vaccinated i
know
about a third of them say if there is
full
fda approval i will go and get
vaccinated that's about a third of the
currently vaccine hesitant based on a
poll from a few weeks ago
do i believe a full third of them are
really going to get vaccinated when
there's fda approval
no i imagine some will say okay well let
me now give it a few months that it's
been fda
approved fully rather than just as
emergency use some of them will
some of them won't what will it take to
get more people vaccinated at this point
i don't know
will it be required vaccinations to go
to sporting events will it be required
vaccinations to travel a lot of these
folks don't travel anyway
i don't know what the answer is but it's
very scary and we are seeing in the
numbers
what we could be facing very very soon
we have
just insane news
news corporation fox news
is going to be launching their own
weather channel
if you can believe it the week is
reporting that fox is launching a
weather streaming service and it is
already
feuding with the weather channel rupert
murdoch is looking to
rain on the weather channel's parade
there's there's a nice uh line
murdoch is set to debut a new streaming
service fox weather this fall
with his company believing that the
quote sometimes stayed world of weather
tv is ripe for disruption
the new york times reports fox weather
is aiming to take on the weather channel
but the times noted that the latter
company is already throwing some shade
at its new competitor
weather channel chief content officer
nora zimmet told the new york times they
couldn't even get a headlight
headline right about tropical storm bill
slamming a recent article on fox news's
website claiming the storm posed a
massive threat
i applaud fox getting into the weather
space but they should really leave the
life-saving information
to the experts that is not really the
issue for me the issue for me is
is the next aspect of this that's
addressed
zimmit added that climate change is too
important to politicize
and if they do that they will be doing
americans a disservice
a fox weather spokesperson pushed back
telling the times
quote while the weather channel is
focused on trolling foxnews.com for
unrelated stories
fox weather is busy preparing the debut
of our innovative platform to deliver
critical coverage
to an incredibly underserved market when
i hear
that fox weather says weather
is an underserved market when it's a
third
of the uh nightly local news on the 6 pm
news in basically every market
on the 11 p.m news in basically every
market if you look at
a half hour of local news those those
half-hour news shows
once you take out commercials it's 21
minutes often
six or seven of those 21 minutes are
weather
a third okay and in addition to that you
have
the weather channel in addition to that
everybody on their phones has
constant live weather and when there are
notable weather events
the major cable networks like msnbc cnn
and fox cover weather
so when i hear fox weather
that weather is underserved what i'm
hearing is there's not enough climate
denial
presented as science and and packaged
as if it is the weather channel and that
is what i fundamentally believe that
this is about
they make billions by uh
playing political theater stoking
polarization
stoking gridlock allowing the people who
say trump really won and all of this
stuff to just
appear on their network they build that
up and then
they build themselves up as the ones who
will tell you the truth
why am i not seeing on the other
networks that trump actually won
well maybe it's because trump didn't
really win no it's because nobody but
fox will tell me the truth
that's the ideology and the attitude
that they
sort of stoke um in their audience
and with a fair amount of climate denial
right remember the clips from fox news
despite it being bitterly cold in the
winter
in north dakota in dc democrats are
talking about climate change those types
of headlines so they've got the perfect
audience for it
and now they will smoothly make the
switch and say hey we'll also tell you
the truth about the weather
and climate which are actually two
different things come on over
this is what they are planning in a
sense
it's brilliant it's evil genius i guess
is what i would call it
weather is going to become a ratings
maker in the sense that it will now be a
proud and defiant alternative to the
fake
news weather that the meteorologists on
the weather channel and elsewhere are
giving you i
if it weren't so obviously going to work
it would be worth laughing at but
because it's probably going to work it's
actually the type of thing we should be
crying over
creating an alternative narrative that
climate deniers can point to and say no
no no no no
fox weather has a different perspective
on this
it's extraordinarily dangerous and it
will be launching uh in a few months
and i am uh genuinely horrified by what
this what this may do because remember
the there is a virus in the u.s
which is people don't even understand
what are facts and whenever i say that
it sounds like i'm using strange syntax
because people assume i'm saying
people don't understand what the facts
are no no no no it's worse
people no longer understand what are
facts
what types of statement are empirical
statements
statements based in the scientific
method for example
versus what are just opinions and when
you don't understand
what is a fact and what is an opinion
which is what fox news specializes in
all hell breaks loose apply that
deranged
system to weather now and
it is a recipe for absolute and total
disaster uh
i don't think i'm being uh exaggerated
in how dangerous this is but i want to
hear from you you can find me on twitter
at deepakman and let me know your
thoughts
i've been on fox news a couple of times
if i'm ever invited back
ground news is one of the first things i
would use to get
my head in the game and prepare myself
for the interview because ground news is
a news source comparison platform
that lets you compare how outlets from
the left right and center
are reporting on a story it makes it
easy to see the nuances of how sources
with differing political biases are
covering a story
and it also shows you your news blind
spot stories that your side of the
political spectrum
may not have covered ground news can
help you
build a well-crafted argument for
debating people you disagree with or
ground news can help you discover
something new
about your own perspective challenging
your own strongly held views on
political issues
be the most informed person in the room
download the
free ground news app today by going to
ground dot
news slash pacman remember that the
david pakman show is made
possible mostly through memberships
people like you who say
i'll sign up uh you can go to
joinpakman.com we do a
daily member only show we've got the the
one hour a day show
but then we've got an extra 15 to 20
minutes with behind the scenes stuff and
a lot of other things
every day for our members you can access
it instantly when you sign up at
joinpakman.com and of course the coupon
code is available
better21 will save you a bunch
off of the membership of your choice
okay as
predicted donald trump was never going
to be reinstated to the white house
in august there is no mechanism for
reinstatement in the united states
constitution or the
in the united states law one of the
biggest
purveyors of these ideas was trump
sycophant mike lindell ceo and founder
of the my
pillow brand who will also be holding
some kind of what he's calling a
symposium on
in sometime in early august whether he
even knows what symposium means
i don't know but he now has a new date
on which he says donald trump will be
reinstated
mike lindell has set august 13
as the date where trump will again
become the president
of the united states this is the first
time he's put
a specific date on this entire thing
a business insider reports on it and
says my pillow
ceo mike lindell says he believed
former president donald trump would take
the impossible step
of being reinstated as
president on august 13.
speaking to brannon howes on the
conservative
wvw broadcast network on sunday
lindell said that by that date trump's
reinstatement
would be the talk of the world donald
trump won
he claimed i mean it's pretty simple
okay
let's take a look at the video in which
mike lindell
says this by the time august 3
the morning of august 13th it'll be the
talk of the world going
hurry up let's get this election pulled
down that's right the right
let's get these communists out and you
know that they've taken over that
and you'll see when i say that you know
and those people what's going to happen
to all the people that were involved i
don't know right now the biggest concern
is getting this election pulled down
donald trump won i mean that's pretty
simple
okay and there were many downticket
senators too that they did too and stuff
you'll find all that off
by the time so in addition to this
degree
of insanity uh mike lindell is also
claiming that
uh at his symposium in august he has
uh voting machines that he is going to
be holding some kind of a
mock election to reenact how the voting
machines
did all the stuff that he claims that
they supposedly did so
there's there's a few different things
going on here that are worth talking
about first of all
you know how many times has the date
changed at this point of course
it's never going to happen it's not
going to be august 13th a couple weeks
ago mike lindell also floated the idea
it might be september
it's never going to happen now a lot of
people come to me and they say
david uh sir um do you think
that mike lindell believes uh
this stuff do you think he actually
believed that donald trump
uh genuinely won the election
congratulations sir you just won the
election
exactly and i think the answer is it
doesn't matter
um if i had to guess i think
that mike lindell has the sense that
there was some fraud he he believes
he doesn't really know whether it's
enough that it would have given the
election to donald trump
but he doesn't care and he's making a
bunch of money he's getting a ton of
publicity he has all of his conservative
friends promoting his pillows you know
everybody's got a coupon code for his
pillows and so on and so forth i don't
think it matters i think the important
thing is
that the big picture of this is a really
really dangerous grift because of
the fact that their followers are so
gullible and
if you think that those followers will
ever learn their lesson when august 13th
comes and goes and oh lo and behold
donald trump
does not become president of the united
states if you think then they will
finally say you know what guys this just
isn't going to happen it's over
look as an analogy at how many times
those evangelical
end of the world apocalypse types have
gotten their dates wrong for the rapture
we've interviewed some of them on the
show and every single time that they get
the date wrong
they go back to their followers and they
say there was a miscalculation
or some bad actor got in the way or
someone didn't pray hard enough or
whatever the case may be
and the exact same thing is what is
going to happen here
either it's the deep state that got in
the way even though it certainly would
have happened if they didn't or whatever
the case may be that's all going to
happen
um the question will be what is the
eventual grift going to be will it
transition into well
the next thing really now is just the
election and it's time to just donate
let's donate and we'll we'll win 2022
and then it'll become 2024. like is that
the grift
is it that some of these people like
mike lindell might run for something in
some way there's been this idea that
mike lindell might run for governor of
minnesota
i don't know ultimately where the grift
is going to go but for now it's been
very profitable for mike lindell and
trump
what whether he believes it or not there
are reports trump does believe it which
is
just wacky i mean just cuckoo for coco
puffs but the reports that
trump believes it um suggests to me
that he also is seeing this as a reason
to reinvigorate those rallies that he's
been doing
and certainly trump making no friends
with most of the people uh that were in
his administration and that's exactly
what i want to talk about
next donald trump had a full complete
and total meltdown
because his former attorney general
william barr
we now know admitted there's no evidence
of any materially significant fraud that
would have affected the election results
in even a single state now that this is
you know when we talk about election
fraud and election integrity
there will often be this question posed
by
people on the right who will say are you
sure
that no one voted twice are you
sure that there was not a single
instance of fraudulent voting and that's
the wrong
question to be asking i have explained
from the beginning
the question is do we have any evidence
that materially significant fraud took
place
that would even maybe change the results
of a single state and remember that if
you just flip georgia
biden still wins if you just flip
arizona biden still wins okay
and and the answer to that is no so we
can't let them get us off on the wrong
question and
along those lines there's a new atlantic
piece
very very interesting piece about
william barr
which says oh and the the piece is um
written by jonathan carl it's called
inside william barr's breakup with trump
this is a really interesting piece not
because it makes william barr
look good william barr is one of the
most disgusting and depraved attorneys
general
it's just that even barr had no choice
but to say you know
you didn't win um the article writes
it's fascinating
in a series of interviews with me this
spring barr spoke for the first time
about the events surrounding his breakup
with trump
i have also spoken with senior officials
in the trump white house and justice
department who provided additional
details about barr's actions
and the former president's explosive
response barr and those close to him
have a reason
to tell his version of this story he has
been widely seen as a trump lackey
who politicized the justice department
but when the big moment came after the
election
he defied the president who expected to
do his bidding
this language of mike
pence defied trump on january 6
and he didn't do well what right
william barr defied trump
it may be in some really narrow sense
accurate
that they didn't do the thing trump
wanted them to do
but they didn't really have a choice
mike pence can't
stop the election from going forward
and joe biden from becoming president of
the united states
trump might think pence could have done
that but pence couldn't do that
and much the same way in in any real
sense i mean barr could have attempted
things
which would have violated all sorts of
law
and the way that elections are run but
in reality the the the
the defiance that we saw from william
barr was just well no he
you he can't get involved there's
nothing that he can actually do
and the article goes on to say bars
betrayal this is amazing
bars betrayal came on december 1 over
lunch in the attorney general's private
dining room with michael balsamo
a justice department beat reporter at
the ap
also in attendance were the doj chief of
staff will leavey
and spokesperson carrie kupec balsamo
was not told the reason for the
invitation when barr
dropped his bombshell between bites of
salad he mumbled
and balsamo wasn't sure that he had
caught what attorney general had said
just to be general balsamo said are you
saying
sir i think you better repeat what you
just said kupeck interjected
barr repeated to date we have not seen
fraud
on a scale that could have affected a
different
outcome in the election this time
balsamo heard him balsamo's story
appeared on the ap new wire
shortly after lunch disputing donald
trump's persistent baseless claims
attorney general william barr declared
tuesday the u.s justice department had
uncovered
no evidence of widespread voter fraud
that could change
the outcome of the 2020 election
once this report went public
donald trump went absolutely and
completely
insane and now of course trump has
a full and complete meltdown this
happened a couple days ago
while we were on our vacation a
statement by donald
j trump look at this look at how quickly
trump turns on people rhino
former attorney general bill barr failed
to investigate election fraud now that's
untrue
even though it's unclear barr should
have been involved in looking into it
barr did look into it and he found no
materials materially significant fraud
trump goes on and really let down the
american people
i would argue the american people are
not let down when democracy actually
gets the right the person who won into
office that's how democracy works
even the scam that took place in georgia
of ballot
stuffing on camera he couldn't see what
was wrong with it now that's a
completely bogus conspiracy
it's been widely debunked just like he
failed to understand the horowitz report
and let everyone down with respect to
getting a timely investigation where's
durham on all of the corruption of the
obama biden administration
he goes on to say and this is slightly
off screen for which i apologize
it's people in authority like bill barr
that allow the crazed radical left to
succeed
he and other rhinos in the republican
party are being used in order to try to
convince people
that the election was legitimate when so
many incredible facts
now come out to show conclusively that
it wasn't none of that is true
trump fully melting down and now going
after
william barr even going further trump
writing
if he felt this boy why did barr say he
was greatly honored and proud to have
played a role
in the many successes and unprecedented
achievements you have delivered to the
american people in the final letter he
wrote to me
because barr's a politician and he's
going out with a completely
standard meaningless pseudo-suck-up
letter
of no value whatsoever he said few could
have weathered these attacks much less
forge ahead with a positive program for
the country
william barr may believe that and yet
have found no voter fraud these are not
mutually exclusive things
um trump also finishing this off by
saying now it was revealed that barr was
being pushed
to tell lies about the election by mitch
mcconnell another beauty
who was worried about damaging the
republican chances in the georgia runoff
what really damaged the senate
republicans was allowing
their races to be rigged and stolen and
worse the american people to no longer
believe their vote matters because
spineless rhinos like william barr and
mitch mcconnell did nothing
um here's my message on this is crazy
out of this world stuff i mean just
of not almost nothing he's saying is
true he got william barr's name right
he got he correctly claimed there were
runoffs in georgia that's true
everything else is lies as cartoonish as
this is
do not get complacent the midterms are
starting essentially in three months the
midterm season
starts unless we want a repeat
of obama's 2010 situation
we have to come out and vote then
there's 2024.
i already told you yesterday a trump
2024 ticket
against biden and or kamala harris
i don't think looks particularly good
and especially if republicans have a
strong 2022 midterm
2024 trump versus biden or trump versus
harris
scares me significantly um
last thought on this every time
trump supporters say we like trump
because he just
he's he cares about america and he's
good for the country
look at these statements look at these
lies and there is
he will say he will attack american
democracy in
absolutely any way that he sees
advantageous to him
he doesn't care about the country he
certainly doesn't care about his
supporters
and he cares about them and other people
only to the extent that they are
politically useful to him
they're about to get useful again his
supporters are about to get useful again
because he needs their money so that he
can play kingmaker in 2022. i can't
think of anything less patriotic
and trump just melting down on and
anyone who simply said
mr president i wasn't able to find any
evidence that you actually won
those now become enemies and they now
become rhinos and unpatriotic or
whatever the case may be it's disgusting
i can't think of anything less patriotic
and we'll have more on this on our
instagram make sure you're following us
there at david pakman show
don't forget that the best way to
support the david pakman show is by
becoming a
member which gives you access to the
daily bonus show the regular show
with no commercials you also get access
to our entire
archive of every episode dating back
a really long time and plenty of other
awesome membership perks go to
joinpackman.com and use the coupon code
better21 for a huge discount
joinpakman.com it's great to welcome to
the program today dr
keltner who's a professor of psychology
at uc berkeley the faculty director of
the greater good
science center and also author of the
book the power paradox which we're
linking to
uh it's great to have you on today david
it's great to be with you
so i i feel like this conversation is
just so relevant in terms of
even just thinking about american
politics right now and the types of
leaders that have
have done well and not so well over the
past many years
maybe just to start with my
understanding
of the sort of machiavellian view of
power
is that at a very crude top level it's
better to be feared
than loved in terms of maintaining
influence and and maintaining that power
what are the flaws with that approach
generally and maybe in particular
today yeah you know the machiavellian
approach of power
you nicely summarized david you know
let's remember it emerged in
the early 1500s probably in one of the
most violent times in human history
and machiavelli wrote this book the
prince and some people
questioned whether he was really being
sincere but the idea of power there is
that you lie
you deceive you pretend that you're
religious when you're not
and you kill your enemies and you
destabilize your allies right so powers
about
fear and uh and uh acquisition
sort of unilateral acquisition and we
we've really changed dramatically as a
human society
in those 500 years as everybody knows
right um
with works more complicated politics are
more complicated
we've seen the rise of rights uh of
different kinds
and so it's it's just a different world
and when you look at
empirical tests of the machiavellian
perspective
do you believe that you should lie and
manipulate and hurt others to rise in
power what you find
is those people don't do as well in
organizations today
they don't do as well in american
politics you know the the classic
machiavellian was
uh president nixon who's now rated as
one of the least effective presidents
uh by historians and we've even done
studies showing they don't do as well
in finance in one of the more
machiavellian contexts so
you know what i argue in the power
paradox is
it might be time to abandon that
philosophy of power it's been wildly
influential
i think it's i think it's at the source
of a lot of today's
environmental and social ills what do
you think or what do you make of
the often repeated idea that
the more unchecked and or unilateral
power one has
the more likely they will be pushed into
bad acts
or or corruption or whatever the case
may be is it that simple
i i think it's it's it's a broad
hypothesis that you just articulated
with many versions right
uh the idea of a democracy is you you
keep power in check
uh and when it's not kept in check as
you suggest david things
get into trouble the idea of journalism
is that you
you speak truth to power you hold the
powerful accountable when
president trump tries to destabilize the
idea of facts and journalism
uh we have the trouble we have today
right where people question the very
notion of a
shared democracy so yeah it's it's
fundamental and you know what's really
interesting david when i did the
research for the power paradox
this is actually a very old idea in the
evolution of
our human species right hunter-gatherer
societies hundreds of thousands of years
old
a very sophisticated analyses show
did this they kept the powerful in check
through social processes through
reputation through
various things that gave rise to our
critical oversight of the powerful
and and i really worry as you probably
do too that you know that
when we lose those capacities to keep
the powerful in check
you get into serious trouble is um
is the sort of machiavellian approach to
power
and governance um in the modern day
essentially equivalent to
authoritarianism in the sense that you
know when i think of of now
about being feared i think about duterte
i think about kim jong-un i think about
putin i think about assad
i sort of think about trump in that i
think he would like to be that
although maybe because of his cartoonish
nature he failed to actually do it in
in practice but he liked a lot of those
authoritarians as well
is that analogous it is and
and it it very much you know this
machiavellian view of dominate
coerce lie manipulate scare
very much finds a home in authoritarian
politics and in fact
some of the most authoritarian
politicians in human history
uh like mussolini were huge fans of
machiavelli
right and kept it kept the prince as a
leadership guide
and and i agree i think that trump you
know wanted to be that but was
kept in check by wall street and
corporations and the like and
uh so thank goodness in some sense so
it does machiavellian and
machiavellianism is very
closely allied with authoritarianism uh
even in the american citizenry we do we
just published a paper showing
kind of um it's interesting you know
white men who have been disenfranchised
in the united states tend to want that
kind of political philosophy to lead
so it's it's a lie and do they want it
because they feel
that it will as they see it
re-enfranchise them
exactly you know and i know and so it's
this interesting
uh quality of american politics that
that we have to grapple with that's
pretty self-evident
i'm this is maybe getting more into sort
of the psychology of power in some sense
but i'm curious what what you think of
it there is this
um i don't know if it's like a
survivorship bias sort of thing
or i don't know exactly what i would
call it but there's definitely this idea
and this happens i think in the business
world this happens in the political
world and
elsewhere where once you achieve a
certain amount of power
success influence whatever over time you
become accustomed to it and you sort of
start to think that like it
it had to be this way it was it's this
way because i deserve it or it's this
way because i'm better or whatever the
case may be and it's
it's very hard to fight that even
sometimes when i like
will mentor smaller youtubers or
something like that
um i because i've been doing this for so
long i'll sort of think like well you
know the
i just did some really basic stuff and
it just sort of like happened
and it would have happened regardless
but it really actually
it's the work and it's the day-to-day
etc there's nothing inevitable about a
lot of this stuff
how does that psychological aspect play
into
how this evolves
you know i i think that's such an astute
observation and and
you know i think one of the most
pernicious
dimensions to american politics
um is this dynamic you're referring to
uh we've studied it in the form of
essentialism right
which is what you find in corporations
and you find in uh organizational
structures
is this idea of people who have power
start to become blind to the breaks they
got
the sources the opportunities that came
their way
by where they were born or um
the just by fate and they start to
develop a sense that it takes special
people to lead
right uh and and it is this sense of
like
wow i i have power there there must be
we justify it we think wow i'm some sort
of
uniquely gifted person to rise to the
top
and why is that perilous because number
one it leads to
and we've done work on this um certain
kinds of ideas about compensation
well maybe i deserve 20 million dollars
a year for the work i do
right it's like a veil of meritocracy in
a sense it is very much so
very much so uh and and the idea of
meritocracy right that
it's really the special people that you
know that get into the special schools
or deserve
certain kinds of compensation or get
treated by the law differently
which we have ample evidence of so i
think it's a really dangerous
corollary of the psychological dynamics
of power that
the powerful think they're above the law
and deserve more than
other people there's these studies that
have been
popularized over the last few years
about how being wealthy particularly for
a long period of time starts to change
the brain in some way and like what
exactly that means we can talk about it
and it's kind of like the devil is in
the details but
does being in a position of power
in the way that you study also have a a
similar effect
yeah you know and this is worked by
supender obi in canada
and uh naomi eisenberger ucla
i mean it's astonishing that you can
give somebody you can place somebody
randomly into a position of power
right i could take you and randomly
assign you to like hey you're in charge
of other people and you're the powerful
one
and and one of the big effects at the
neurophysiological level is that it
it tends to deactivate
the empathy regions of your brain
i've got to do some tough stuff i might
not have done this before but now that
i'm in this position it's just what i
have to do
right but but what i worry about with
the the deactivation of these empathy
regions and we've also found power
deactivates the vagus nerve which is a
big bundle of nerves in your chest that
helps you connect
and be kind to other people so suddenly
when powerful people are acting in more
greedy fashion
they're not sensitive to suffering
they're not aware of other people to the
extent that they used to be
we now have a neurophysiological
understanding of that that power
you know one person put it dramatically
like it shuts down
your empathy regions that's a little
dramatic but
it's on the way towards what's true of
power
so the paradox or at least what one one
of the paradoxes that you talk about is
individuals or groups or whoever they
get power
and the idea is that they're being
empowered
in order to do things for a group of
people but the more power they get
for a lot of the different reasons
you've talked about starts to
limit their ability to really fully
think about
how they can keep the interests of
everyone
uh sort of in mind in their actions
right i mean like this is sort of the
paradox that we're talking about
yeah you know and you just nailed 25
years of my life studying power in
different ways
right but thank you you know yeah you
know
what surprise what may surprise people
is but once you start thinking deeply
about it there's
a lot of truth to this and and we've
looked at like
who gains power in hunter-gatherer
societies sports teams
non-profits government even finance etc
and it's people like you said david who
and hannah arendt really put it well
as did michelle foucault who
you gain power by advancing the greater
good by advancing the interests of the
people around you
that is just a basic law right
and so you do it through promoting
strong social networks and
and sharing knowledge and distributing
resources that
leads you to rise in the ranks and then
regrettably through these psychological
processes we've been talking about once
i feel powerful and i'm seduced
by myself you know i start
you know acting unethically and failing
to attend to people's thoughts or
recommendations
and not feeling for other people so
that's the paradox of power as
as we rise in some sense to advance
other people's interests
but when we feel powerful we work
against it have the stakes sort of
changed
in the sense that for example like in
jared diamond's work
he's written a lot about how the ability
to cooperate
and the ability to advance the greater
good for your
you know maybe clan of 150 people at
that point
not being the team player etc you could
be out and you could be dead
right like the stakes were were very
very uh
life or death maybe in some senses in
2021 that applies but it feels as though
maybe the stakes have changed to a
degree
yeah i think that's the big question
right
which is and you put it really and this
is christopher baum
who really wrote about hierarchies and
that jared diamond's commenting upon
which is that
you had to cooperate and be
interdependent and work collectively
to survive for a couple hundred thousand
years
and today in some sense um you
a lot of the basic processes that
enabled that cooperation have been
degraded
right so our ability to hold leaders
accountable
you know in the the financial collapse
of 2008 i don't think anyone i think one
person was prosecuted
right so that just means you can go do
whatever you want to do
if you're white and privileged and and
not be held accountable
that's problematic to this mod this
cooperative model of power
i worry about uh certain contexts that
teach this machiavellian you know
self-interested above others model of
of how to lead you know you see that in
important institutions like you know
certain business schools and certain
views of
economic views of human nature so so
yeah you know i think you're you're
framing it really i wish i'd framed that
in that fashion in the power power which
is we had this
workable model of power right for
hundreds of thousands of years
and now it's been degraded and we see
levels of greed and environmental
destruction even
that come out of this model of power
that we that may cause our demise
the book is called the power paradox
we've been speaking with the book's
author dr keltner professor of
psychology
at uc berkeley so great having you on i
really appreciate your time
thanks for your thoughtful questions
david
if you value what we do at the david
pakman show remember to support us on
patreon
go to patreon.com david pakman show
where you can get access to behind the
scenes videos
the daily bonus show the commercial free
daily show
as well as special discounts on merch
including
hats hoodies mugs and t-shirts
you can support the show for as little
as
two dollars a month check it out at
patreon.com
david pakman show one of the really
worrying trends
in the united states right now really
under this new modern republican party
call it whatever you want trumpian or
whatever the case may be
the thing is that facts truly do not
matter anymore
and rewriting history to suit whatever
point you're trying to make today
it has become a completely acceptable
means to an end it doesn't matter how
you rewrite history it doesn't matter
what lie you tell about the past
as long as it supports whatever point
you're trying to make today
it's okay for this modern republican
party here's one new example from the
4th of july weekend
donald trump's former press secretary
kaylee mcinanny appeared on fox news
and the context was making the point
that conservatives are victims
and that democrats are unpatriotic and
kaylee wildly claimed that the founding
fathers the main
founding fathers were all against
slavery
this is a lie it's just a big fat lie
and we're going to look at what she said
and the context was that democratic
congresswoman corey bush
said that july 4th is sort of a
celebration for white people
corey bush said when they say that the
fourth of july is about american freedom
remember
the freedom they're referring to is for
white people in the sense that we are
celebrating the anniversary of a country
which at year one the date that is being
celebrated was
one in which black people uh were
enslaved
in the united states that's the context
okay
let's look at what kaylee mcinanni had
to say about it
starting with you bill bennett the
haters never take a day off
from hating that is clear and they never
take a day off of getting the facts
wrong we know most of our forefathers
all of our main founding fathers were
against slavery recognize the evils of
it there's a great piece to that end on
heritage called 1776 not 16
19 but i'll leave it to you you know
they're so wrong on so much
where to begin yes so that is completely
untrue okay that's
really really really not true let's
actually go through this
because there's there's an opportunity
to actually learn a little something
here
the majority of the founding fathers of
the united states owned
slaves now you could say well they owned
them but they were against it
we're gonna come back to that okay but
but they they were not against it enough
not to have their own slaves now i'm
talking about benjamin franklin
john hancock john john jay um thomas
jefferson james madison george
washington and many others
they they own slaves some of the names
you might not recognize as readily
there were a few founding fathers that
did not own slaves
john adams and samuel adams in
massachusetts for example
thomas paine i don't believe is known to
have owned slaves okay
so when kaylee mcinanni says most of the
founding fathers were against
slavery mostly they owned slaves
now what is true is that over time
many founding fathers including some
that own slaves
started to recognize some problems with
slavery
some realized rightly that slavery was
antithetical to the concept of freedom
and liberty on which the u.s was
supposedly based
but some of them seemed more to be
thinking about it
almost like economically uh thomas
jefferson condemned the injustice of the
slave
trade in the initial draft of the
declaration of independence
but there are counterpoints about
whether did that mean he was against
slavery or did he just not like the
slave trade as it was being carried out
internationally so even that i mean i'm
sure people will write in and say no
david that's super clear it was either
this or it was that
there's there's some ambiguity to it but
he owned slaves
and then you had some who really wanted
to change nothing about
whether slavery was federally legal and
just say it's a state issue
now if for example slave owner benjamin
franklin
slave owner owner benjamin franklin in
pennsylvania
supported anti-slavery causes but not
federally you know if
if south carolina wants to keep having
slaves well that's their thing but in
pennsylvania we shouldn't have slaves
necessarily so
to call that being anti-slavery again
that this is pretty nebulous in many
ways so the point here is
was the opinion on slavery of the
founding fathers
maybe more complex than they were either
for it or against it absolutely
did some founding fathers have seemingly
inconsistent positions on slavery
absolutely did some of them change their
views on slavery over time
yes no no doubt about it but is kaylee
mcinanny right when she says most of the
founding fathers were against slavery
no that's a complete and total lie and
the point here of what kaylee mcinanni
did
was simply to try to attack corey bush
by saying when corey bush says july 4th
really celebrates freedom for white
people
because at the time black people were
enslaved
kaylee wants to say well no we're the
founding fathers were all against
slavery and that is simply
inaccurate and so her entire defense
falls apart now
whether you agree that july 4th
is a pro-slavery holiday or a
celebration of an
era when there was slavery that that's a
debate that's a debate you can have and
you can say well okay yes
we're celebrating the anniversary of a
date at which
there was slavery we no longer have that
we can still recognize that this is a
milestone in the existence of the
country without being in agreement with
all the things that the country did at
the time
right then you're in the weeds you're in
the details but kaylee mcinanni is just
wrong
and this is the exact type of little
pithy talking point
that the average fox news viewer will
never investigate and will simply start
to repeat and repeat and repeat it's sad
more than anything else
i don't know what's going on uh guys
with fox news
but sean hannity will not stop talking
about trump's dementia test they they
just will not
stop talking about it and celebrating it
like some kind of major achievement here
is a new clip
from yesterday this was from yesterday's
sean hannity program
and again hannity talking about
trump's dementia screening test that is
there nothing else to talk about for
this guy
and talk about the cognitive side of
things donald trump took
that cognitive test you told me
that he passed it with a perfect score
30 of 30.
sir doctors have never seen such a
perfect score
it's unbelievable sir sir sure
yeah um just hannity's really impressed
told me it's a hard exam
you told me that you want joe biden to
take one
what has been the response
none i haven't heard a single thing sean
and you're right this is not a laughing
matter anymore why
does the biden administration have to
respond
to trump's former doctor the same guy
who said trump is 6'3 in ways 239 by the
way
why does the biden administration have
to respond to that
uh i i simply don't get it and
this is just everybody's obsessed with
this now and of course the idea is it's
a distraction narrative
to try to get the attention on something
other than the complete absurdity of
what the republican party has become
here's just a reminder
here's trump ranting about his cognitive
test at the u.s mexico border last week
but he did a test did i ace it
i aced it and i'd like to see biden ace
it
he won't ace it he'll get the first two
there's 35 questions and
the first two or three are pretty easy
they're the animals
is this a lion a giraffe when he gets to
around 20 he's going to have a little
hard time i think he's going to have a
hard time with the first few actually
yeah so as i told you yesterday there
are not 35
questions there's 30 points it's like 19
to 23 questions depending on how you
count them
and again trump obsessed with the idea
that this is a hard test
this is just a way to screen relatively
serious cognitive decline or dementia
um and then again with hannity i mean
what what's pathetic is
it's become a way to suck up to trump
they suck
up to trump by saying you you're not
demented
essentially is what's happening in
trouble with coming we aced it i think i
can say that i aced it
did he get one he didn't get one
question wrong did he
30 out of 30. wow
and they did get the crowd cheering guys
the crowd cheering for it a little more
difficult after you get by 15 i would
say but
i heard the first three questions are is
it a giraffe or an elephant right
well you know that's what the fact is is
they take the first two or three
questions and they put that
and they put them in it's a really tough
time i mean i looked at it guys it's
tougher than what you know in high
school i did ap
economics and that was that was an easy
one
the trump dementia test was really
really tough so how long will this
obsession go on
i really have no idea but it's very very
strange
i got a really interesting voicemail
that i want to play for you of course
you can call the voicemail number
any time of day the number is 219 to
david p
here is a voicemail about why do people
who are anti-semitic
claim to love israel it doesn't make
sense
hey david i was just wondering if you
had any insights into
why these people that hate jews so much
are so pro-israel
i don't get it thank you there's a
couple different things going on
number one um a lot of the evangelical
support for israel
is not rooted in any uh
desire to provide a safe haven
for jews that have been persecuted in
you know dozens and dozens of countries
for a thousand years or longer it's
it's not rooted in that for many
evangelicals it's rooted in
we believe the second coming of jesus
will happen
when there is a strong israel and then
there's a bunch a bunch of different
versions of it
when a temple is rebuilt or what
whatever okay but basically they believe
that the second coming of jesus will
happen if they support israel others
believe the rapture
will happen if they support israel for
some it's one in the same
there's all these different sects and
and they tend to have different beliefs
so that's
part of it um and then for many others
on the right
um it's either just they sort of like
militarism
and they like the idea of there's other
countries that have some of the cool
advanced
weapons that we have and or uh
they see it as a way to sort of fight
proxy wars against populations they
don't like in the middle east but
it's not it's i understand that it
sounds like wait
a lot of these people are anti-semitic
they often play into anti-semitic tropes
repeat them etc but they claim to
support israel
they are two completely different things
and uh
much the same as what is going on with
american anti-semitism
uh is a separate issue from israeli
foreign policy
the anti-semites who claim to like
israel are sort of operating in two
different spaces and it might sound like
it's one incoherent space and to some
degree it is
but for many of them these are
completely different issues there's the
political state of israel
and then there's jews about whom they
have
uh uh prejudiced beliefs
in the united states and sort of the
day-to-day community it's a very good
question because it does seem
incoherent and inconsistent and in a
sense it absolutely is
we have a great bonus show for you today
i'm out of time but trust me it's a good
one
sign up at jointpakman.com and you'll
get instant access
thanks a lot for watching today's show i
just want to take a second to tell you
about today's sponsors
ground news is combating divisiveness
in media ground is a news comparison
platform
that helps you see multiple perspectives
for any news story
so you can be more of a well-rounded
news reader
download the free app at news
slash pacman